Thanks are coming everybody so indeed my
story what I'll tell you is I'll share
you with you what we learned over the
last two years or so at past show right
where we make react and in this journey
we learned a bunch a lesson some things
work some things didn't so as per the
title hopefully you'll walk away with it
from this talk with some ideas about
lessons that you could apply trying to
figure out integrate no sequel stores in
too far so I got a fair amount to cover
us all dive right in so I'll start with
an equation and the equation here is you
have no sequel and starting with you
know the normal flavors and as well as
mentioned you know we're a key value
store so a lot of what I'll focus on and
what we learned to do was optimizing key
value for spark so you take this
equation you have your no sequel
database and you have spark and what do
you wind up with becomes a bit of a
question mark right sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't I think a lot of
folks in this room have been through
this experience trying to figure out how
am I going to marry these two worlds
which don't always necessarily speak the
same language so the crux of it is going
to be and too often you're gonna wind up
with this unhappy face right and the
crux of this conversations going to be
how do we turn this frown and turn it
upside down right so hopefully in half
an hour we'll see how to do that so we
built a connector right so a big part of
what we did here was we built a
connector between react and spark and a
lot of what we and it impacted both what
we did in the connector itself but also
what we did in the core product of react
and here are five lessons so this will
be the agenda for this discussion first
of all it's this idea of a parallelized
right anybody who's worked with spark
knows that it loves to parallel eyes so
that was for us the number one thing to
do was figure out okay how can we
maximize parallelization the second one
was this idea of mapping smartly we go
back to the mapping smartly so in this
case it's mapping data mapping right so
once you get data across
us how are you going to be make that as
efficient as possible to work with it in
spark right you've taken out of a key
value store I don't know sequel how
we're going to do this as easily as
possible in spark the third is going to
be optimized sort of optimizing all the
layers optimizing all the things and we
spend a lot of time and energy thinking
about optimization four and five are
slightly different because those are
really about deployment and how do you
simplify the actual use of what we've
built right because building connectors
building libraries using libraries isn't
always the easiest thing in the world so
to level set react has been around for a
while right we're a distributed no a
sequel key value store modeled on the
old anima amazon dynamo paper we have a
very large client base in enterprise but
a lot of open source projects we have
it's primarily an erlang shop so we're
Erlang C++ some client libraries about
eight or nine different languages we are
a distributed company in the sense of we
have about 40 core engineers on the team
and they're all over the world we don't
have a headquarters in terms of
engineering so and we are hiring by the
way so if you want to work remotely on
some interesting really hard disturbia
systems problems talk to us afterwards
and it's open source and we of course as
many vendors do we have enterprise
features such as multi data center
replication so that's react so we
started to see when this journey started
for us is about two years ago customers
starting to ask for things like time
series IOT data analytics more metrics
right so those use cases then made us
from a product perspective think more
about what should we be doing and we did
two things primarily one is we build a
whole new product called react TF which
is react time series so it's optimized
for time series data and then the other
thing we did was build the spark react
connected
so those of you some of you here are
familiar with ria kv it's great for
high-volume throughput on user data
session data used by the national health
service uber bestbuy where you need to
have high volume so time series data as
you many of you know it's going to be
slightly different and so the use cases
for that where I OT metrics and so on
but they use the same react or
infrastructure right so that same
infrastructure is still there the same
back end so we use leveldb in pit cask
and a couple other pluggable backends
you use and if you think about what was
next necessary to change for time series
for us that meant adding more structure
to it so with time series it's not just
key value it's you actually have a
schema you can say create table so
there's more structure here and this
will play into some of what I show you
later in terms of some of the
architectural decisions that we may
along with that then there's that subset
of sequels so you can do selects and
joins and aggregations within the time
series product and then lastly a lot of
this is get optimized for this rapid
incoming stream of data so it's
optimized for high write volumes and
then queries based on time slice and so
we'll talk about that because again you
think about spark they fit well together
and one good example of somebody is
using the time series product right now
or the guys at atelic or I don't know
whether anybody in the audience is
familiar with formula e racing the
formula car racing but they're all
electronic now so and they go to zero to
one hundred and three seconds it's
street racing it's company called aunt
Ella core build a commercial product for
those race teams using react es as the
back end and they do they're set up to
do about 40,000 TPS that there's a fair
amount of telemetry that comes from
those races in real-time and then they
have real-time apps that you can put
that the race teams themselves use and
then they can distribute that out so
there's a fair amount of processing
going on and a fair amount of data in
and out
in real time and here's what that app
looks like so again this is from atelic
or for this formula e racing so the
second bit of background I want to give
you is the park connector so we did the
first version was published last fall
and the most recent one 1 dot 6 came out
last month so it's fairly new the one
died 6 it's a scala app you can download
it just like react it it's open-source
supports park 1 dot 6 we're working on
spark 20 and we it also supports
Scotland Python Java in terms of
actually using it so 3 use cases read
write and streaming and also go into
each of these in more detail right
reading pulling that data out that's the
number one use case you can write back
from spark if you need to and then you
can make react a sink or a streaming
scenario and when we built the connector
we built the connector based on what we
had learned building other connectors so
to solar to mezzos to to read it so for
for caching on the right side so lesson
number one parallel eyes whenever
possible and I'll walk you through a
couple of zeros here that don't work
here's a react cluster on the left right
you got the spark cluster on the right
and the operative question is going to
be how am I going to move a boatload of
data from the reactor over to spark as
quickly as possible and if you think
about it a kv k values Kate key value
store the most common way to do that is
you're going to do a get right you're
gonna have a key you're gonna say give
me the value so if you look at the way
that works here you can have the spark
workers go off you have a cluster each
one will go off and it'll say give me
some you know you'll get and again and
again and I'll get all that data back
and the next node will get the data back
but the problem is is that the spark
side quickly becomes unhappy right
because you're asking the spark side to
do a boatload of work react is totally
happy it's a key value store it'll do
that till till the cows come home I
so the moral that lesson which I would
call lesson 1 a is too many gets makes
bark unhappy so that's one let's try the
flip side of that which is using a
secondary index on the react side so to
use that secondary index you'll have a
spark work or go over to a coordinating
note on the react side so that that node
in the cluster says okay here's my query
let me go figure out how to get that
data as efficiently as possible the
other thing goes off to other nodes
knowing where that data is distributed
and pulls that back and then send that
back too far the next bark worker will
go off and do the same thing right and
the third will be the same thing and I
think you might be able to guess it or
where the bottleneck becomes in this
scenario it's on the react side right
because now we're asking them to do all
the work and that's lesson one babe
which is that too many to I queries
makes react unhappy right so we've
served burdened what on the right-hand
side we've heard on the left-hand side
so what's the solution the solutions
were going to be we call a coverage plan
plus parallel extract so the way that
this works is spark worker makes the
request over to react and says okay
here's what I need here's my query it
react comes back with what we call a
coverage plan which is going to be a
list of nodes which says where that data
is stored within the cluster right so
that's the coverage fund that now that
the bark side has that that can then in
turn be distributed using again the
spark react connector and that guy can
then turn around and say Oh each one of
those can in parallel because it knows
exactly which nodes to go to and when we
gave that coverage plan back that
coverage plan tried to optimize it so is
going to the fewest number of nodes
right so in this case we try to make the
take the best of both of those worlds of
what's great on the react side with
great on the spark side and parallel
eyes and use this parallel extract on
the coverage plan to make everybody
happy right so for us that was of lesson
number one how can we maximize that took
a fair amount of engineering to make
that work
number two is the mapping piece right
it's an hour we've sort of tried to
tackle that question of moving a lot of
data over as efficiently as possible
from one to the other and in react
you'll have that classic key value store
but we also again have this time series
data and that comes in as a bunch of
different format so I could be as you
know almost anything but but the spark
side really wants to have our dd's and
wants to have data frames and a tu lado
wants to have data sets right the more
structure the better right and so how
are we going to get that whole process
working as efficiently as possible this
is what we were trying to to make
happens I'll show you so how that works
one more go to background right those
who don't know how react works I've got
key value but we also those are grouped
into buckets which are effectively
virtual namespaces it doesn't
necessarily control where they get
placed on the cluster but it gives you a
way of identifying them and in
particular you can then set property
such as replication factors and
consistency consistency attributes in
the bucket so that'll show up in a
second so in this case you're going to
say the way the connector works is
you'll specify a bucket you'll load the
data into our DD and our DD is the most
fundamental basic unit of computation on
the spark side so to make that work
here's what it would look like in a
little bit of Scala code so the first
step is I'm going to say here's my
bucket I'm going to specify that
namespace and then I'm going to make
that call and again Scala and then at
the end there you'll see that the last
item is query all so it says give me
everything in that bucket and then I'll
work with that over here and far right
so this is part of the idea of allowing
spar to do what it does best and depend
on how you've done your data modeling
you know part of the recommendation here
is he thought you know typically about
how am i what what query patterns am I
going to have and how am I going to set
up my buckets to optimize for those
we'll come back to that and there are a
bunch other ways you can query that data
right you can query based on keys so
here's Alice and Bob and Charlie as keys
get them that way there's the 2i range
where you give a numeric range a little
those out and then or by just a set of
strings and says this last one here says
you know get me january-february right
but the idea is you wind up with a bunch
of our d DS and spark and then you can
work with them over there and the way
that you know we were thinking about
that that's fine that work that gets you
going but again we're talking about how
to do this better and in our use case I
think maybe for a lot of folks here
certainly our customer base they store
this JSON right so the value in the key
value is JSON and so that what that
allows us to do is we can tell spar how
to interpret that so we're doing some
interpolation and a retrospection
introspection on the way out to do this
more smartly so i'll show you how that
looks and we wind up with is data frames
which is a higher level computational
more structured unit in spar right so
awful you'll want to be in data frames
as opposed to already DS right this is a
good thing so to make that in code you
see that it's one more step here first
of all we've specified a bucket the
second step here is where we do a case
class in scala and so we're going to say
we have an ID a name and an H right that
that's what's in our schema we're in our
JSON data I should say and that next
line and under load data is exactly the
same right but the the difference part
is that very last part where I can say
to DF on what I got back so I got back
on our DD with that which is that set
and then I can say to DF and then i'm
working with a much more you know often
a preferable place to be in spark which
is data frames so we've done those three
steps in key value rights you said
specify where to go get it I'm going to
get it here's how I'm going to map the
schema and I'm going to back but if you
look at time series data which I alluded
to before for us it's different what's
different about time series for us is
that it already has a structure right we
did a create table right and so what
that's going to allow us to do is a week
and then do automatic schema discovery
and that allows us to then in turn skip
that middle step so we go straight from
specifying a bucket to loading the data
but what we have when we've loaded the
data as we have data frames
so when you do that which you wind up
with is a sight longer piece of code is
going to show you a couple of details
first of all because it's time series
data in our case you specify a table
name so at the top or not specify in a
bucket we're specifying a table name and
in that context read-option there we
specify as you can see the where to go
get it it could be a list of hosts in
the cluster or you can specify one the
format and then the load we're already
doing a select as you can see here we're
already starting to use some of the
sequel capabilities in the time series
data to pull that back out and then we
can filter it and then you can do things
and this is where if those you have any
use for it and most of you probably have
here you can start to do much more
intelligent things so i can do aware
right i can select i can group by i can
do all those other things which i would
necessarily do as intelligently if i
were doing it an RDD right so by moving
that up one level we've been trying to
be smarter about that mapping of the
schema that we've brought over right and
make that fewer steps to try and get
that back and make that usable for the
spark side those of you who might want
to do this yourself SPARC architecture
Lee has a data store layer and they have
an interface that you can implement to
build a library like this yourself so I
think there are three interfaces and do
and there I think we did two of them so
that's where a lot of the magic happens
underneath the covers in terms of doing
this translation pulling this data in is
we've implemented the spark data source
API so that's the second lesson the
third lesson for us was I think this is
also reserved dive into a bit more
general this otha the idea of
optimization right so it's optimized all
the all the layers really it's optimized
all the things all the layers and we'll
start with this idea of for react we
have two primary interfaces you either
can use HTTP or use protocol buffers
when this has been true for eons that
means really since the product lodged
one's about flexibility one's about
performance
nosy just a level setting I think most
folks know but protocol buffers right is
a it's a serialization interchange
format developed by google you specify
your IDL it makes our pc calls but at
the end of the day it's a binary wire
format right lots of language support
and in and and in react you don't have
to necessarily worry about that because
their client library see nine times out
of ten you'll be using and all that
dirty goo has been hidden from you
anyway but it does play into some of the
optimizations first of all folks often
want to know well how much faster
protocol buffers in using HTTP so we've
done a bunch of performance testing and
on average is between one hundred fifty
percent to three hundred percent faster
to use protocol buffers sent to you hcp
right so that's a noticeable difference
if you look at this diagram going back
to that first lesson right on pulling
that data across that's what's happening
on youth the covers there as that spark
connector is going over between the
clusters right all that data being
transferred as protocol buffers and as
we started doing this we started having
some folks try this out we realized
there was a place that we could make
this faster the protocol buffers was
great but we can also do this thing
called that we think of as optimized
binary are there any airline programmers
in here two three so underneath the
covers with our line you can do
something called term to binary or
binary term which is their own
serialization format and so since we're
primarily Erlang shop that's what we do
underneath the cover so what happens is
that when you make a call you make a
query to in spark saying here's the data
i won if you happen to be making certain
types of calls the driver itself will
say oh wait a minute i'm not going to
use i'm not gonna use protocol buffers
i'm going to use term to binary i'm
going to use this other optimized format
and that's really for these calls around
fetching query things are closer to bulk
operations in particular where we can
make them more efficient on the server
side so we don't see that much benefit
to doing this on say the Java side or
the Scala side when you're making the
call itself but we see a much better
band
on the server side we're getting that
data and then sign it back to spark and
that's to the order of thirty to fifty
percent better so again that's not
negligible right that is a meaningful
difference depending on the amount of
data that you're trying to pull across
so you have that sort of tier of HTTP as
a transport or as a protocol they're
going up four protocol buffers to make
that faster and in this case for the
right set of calls thinking about how
kind of make those faster right so those
were our primary lessons at that level
another two more use case optimizations
I just want to throw out there to think
about first of all it's this idea of
full bucket wreath and I showed you
earlier right that you could say query
all we get a query all it's going to go
around the cluster and do a full bucket
reads that's a relatively newer feature
for react is that you don't necessarily
have to have that list of keys you have
to maintain that list of key somewhere
you just happen to know oh I've named
this bucket with this virtual namespace
and that's what I need so again in terms
of your data modeling thinking about
what my query pad are going to be and
then optimizing my bucket structure for
that as well it doesn't necessarily
change data locality with them cluster
that doesn't really change but it really
does help on the query side react es on
the other hand does change the way the
data gets laid out in the cluster right
because when you're thinking about time
series data locality of reference really
makes it different so all that streaming
time but often time based data coming in
you want to lay it as close as possible
as you can the last data so I'll give
you a couple examples so on the on the
left-hand side you have a classic key
value of query right you're going to put
in this case we're going to write the
data and based upon how it got hash look
at evenly distributed around the cluster
and any node can handle it it's
masterless right so rijeka set up as a
masterless architecture so that's not
sharted but those puts get consistently
hashed around the cluster time-series
distributes the data but it's often
looking at grouped based on time quanta
so when you design your data model youth
about how much data do I have coming in
when and what how well I should group
this by a minute an hour a day what is
that logical grouping mechanism in order
so I can lay that data off around the
cluster in order both to speed up my
rights but also to speed up my wreath
and then here's a get so the get does
the same thing as to put in a sense of
oh I know what this query is coming in
from spark therefore I'm going to make
sure that I've you know I know where to
go get a faster Reich's can be on the
same cluster the same node here's how
you would define that as a schema and I
sort of called us out mostly because if
you sort of look towards the bottom
there so here's a weather structure but
you'll see it's got region state and
quantum and that quantum piece has time
to and H that says I want those if at
all possible we put on the same V note
or the same physical node in my cluster
because I don't know what my data
pattern is going to be so for both
either puts and or get some reading and
writing that data that's i'm going to
optimize on my time series data right
and again this is this bottom is the key
to tunable performance and then to query
it out you could say select star from
whether we're cities equal to New York
and pull that out right so that's how
that query might look that's very sequel
like unlike traditional key value store
right but it's also optimized for
pulling it out in this case I said give
me a day with dependent what is your
intend you to do with it over on the
spark side you know your mileage may
vary you choose what that should look
like lesson number four is the idea of
being flexible so in many ways this is a
bit less technical of an optimization
here or a you know a lesson because it's
about for example in in spark land these
the languages that you really care about
for the most part right so as we were
building this we were making sure that
we had tested it at all all three of
these we had used it in Jupiter notebook
so we'd used it from far kept from
skylabs Java Python apps to make sure
that all these were supported
so if you're building these for either
for your you know not just for your own
teams use but for organizations use or
third party really behooves you to think
about this kind of flexibility so how am
I gonna allow people to consume this as
easily as possible so for us it was
these three languages um and here's a
quick example of Python to pull that
together right so the Python example you
have your sort of saying again where's
my cluster i'm going to set up the
context and spark i got it here's an
example to write in the data so I'm
going to parallel eyes it I think I save
it to react right so it's really not
that hard and then the read again is it
going to be all that widely different
than what i showed you before and again
i'm doing the query all and there's two
of the earlier lessons that are sort of
implicit in here right because you can
see that in number two here in the right
it says parallel lives right so you're
taking that that list of data and i'm
going to say ok when i do the right here
from spark i want that to be done in
parallel i mean granted it doesn't
matter with it with the two or three
items but we're talking about volume it
does matter and the same as the query
alright so again thinking about how to
apply the earlier lessons whatever
language you're working in another bit
of flexibility is streaming right I
hadn't beginning that we support
streaming so this is the classic spark
diagram from them about what streaming
looks like in the spark world right you
take things out of kafka cues or
whatever in your data pipeline pump it
into spark and then you can push that
back out so react can be a sink so part
of what this connector does is thinking
about how can we be in sync for that
data and so here's an example what that
looks like in code you set it up you set
up the context by the way these are no
spark that well that seconds is how big
a batch I want to pull out of that
stream so as I sort of pulling those
windows out of the stream in this case
I'm saying give me one second worth and
then I pull that back out and I get the
lines back out and then I can filter
them and then I can save them back right
so but again it's the same idea of what
are the primary use cases in spark one
of the primary uses gazes for me and my
organization or my app well as I'm sort
of connecting these two worlds to wind
up with a happy face
a couple other flexibility notions real
quick or you know for both spark and
react and many of the tools use right
you can do it any one of these flavors
but it's not always obvious which one
makes the most sense so for example
here's the idea of co-locating the two
right so on the left-hand side you have
spark and react working on the same
nodes you could do that it's not
required certainly by our connector but
I think I'll quite often that's not a
good idea right spark is a memory hungry
beast it wants as much horsepower as you
can possibly give it right that model on
the right is more flexible because okay
they are granted I'm giving each one
more horsepower right more memory more
CPU demand with white boxes look like
right on the left you're going to need
bigger more vertical boxes I think on
the right it's easier to do with more
commodity boxes and on the right you
know again you're gonna have to pay that
price of pulling that data across you
kind of helpful have what your network
looks like but you can do it the other
way right again it depends on what your
configuration looks like and which Y
ends up being a better scenario but I
think more often our testing it's going
to be that sort of linearly scalable
configuration on the right and one last
flexibility item is this idea of using
meza so we've also built an open source
framework for connecting react to mezzos
so you can so pull all these together
and run this on a mezclas cluster if you
want to do that so another bit of open
source software that we built in the
last year and last but not least this
idea of simplification and how do I
reduce friction and I'll just throw out
a couple quick ideas here first of all
spark packages so bark packages org
allows you to deploy as you know it's a
repository for the libraries in this
case well any library and even in our
case that's the connector so if you look
down here sort of two-thirds away down
you'll see revoking spark shell and it
says dash dash packages and that just
can in your cluster that'll magically
pull down those packages from spark
packages and so that just saves you some
deployment headache
in managing all of this so we found
spark package to be a great place to put
this up and then you know a library
usages often only as good as the docs
behind it so we partnered with the data
bricks guys and so we have a notebook
sort of a Jupiter style or a data brick
style notebook up on spark that allows
you to walk through and make all this
work interactively just by using a
notebook but I think those are examples
of figuring out how to be the flexible
and simplifying the actual usage of
whatever you in this case what we build
with just a spark and I'll throw them
one last bonus lesson which is don't die
and for us as you know servers die in
clusters all the time so in this case
here if a react node dies during data
retrieval as we're pumping all the stuff
back and forth the spark connector will
go back again what we call an
alternative coverage plan so that'll say
okay well you're not getting from that
node here's a better plan for getting
that data as it quickly and efficiently
as possible so the lessons just for us
where we're going next I think this is
true for a lot of people working in
spark world spark 20 which has data sets
and structured streaming so those are
two really interesting pieces for us
that's what we're looking to do and then
really going back to our original
question right if this is the equation
how do you get turn that frown upside
down for us it was these five lessons
and that's my talk and keep it we're
hiring thanks
[Applause]
and there's office hours shortly so
we'll also be able to talk over there I
have a two-part question was just I know
you talked about how you optimize the
cave en TS + park any plans to do that
for the s2 for the S to go first for the
s2 yeah so we're looking at that as well
because for those of you don't know
that's our big object storage and you
may be a user of that and so we're
looking at how to do that as well
obviously a different set of
optimizations we're gonna have to make
because you're gonna have to chunk them
right we're talking about objects will
be you know gigabytes in size the
strategy all have to be slightly
different okay and second part is is
more about react in general how big a
fluster can react go to because I mean
it is are you guys using a land
distribution re did you write your own
libraries because a line distribution is
more of everyone knows about each other
way yeah so the in terms of the
architecture for react a lot of that was
borrowed originally 2008-2009 when we
first built it from that Amazon dynamo
so there's uses a gossip protocol to
keep all those nodes and sync and it
does use this sir peter lying underneath
the covers so you know trying to use the
best of what Erlang provides but also
those same principles that were outlined
and the originals of dynamo ideas about
replication and clustering and quorums
and consistency that big investor have
have you seen this being used used for
how many nodes in the cluster like
maximum on that you have seen I don't
know
100
yeah another big use case for us with
the weather company does she enormous
volumes of data with react as a back end
yeah hrp we we gotta I think our peak
was something like 70 nodes and we
didn't really notice any sort of
problems with having that number of no I
mean was a fundamental principle is
going to be linearly scalable with that
consistent hashing okay great oh I have
a one kind of a detailed question so
when when the spark cluster gets a
coverage plan what happens if the
location of data like changes in you
know I can no time periods like you know
like a new note comes in or something
and yeah so it comes back the
alternative the alternate coverage plan
so it's the same since is avaible dies
or Sam okay